the impeachment of President Trump is
moving one step closer to a vote this
morning as both sides make their legal
case before the House Judiciary
Committee Nancy Cordes is on Capitol
Hill with more on this story Nancy good
morning to you exactly what is happening
today
well there are going to be three
congressional lawyers scale at the
witness table today and they're going to
take turns establishing what we do and
don't know so far and then taking
questions from lawmakers on the House
Judiciary Committee which is finalizing
those articles of impeachment as soon as
this week the president is engaged in a
course of conduct that threatens the
integrity of the next election that will
be the message from Democrats today as
top lawyers from both sides lay out all
the evidence gathered so far I think the
case we have if presented to a jury
would be a guilty verdict and about
three minutes flat House judiciary chair
Jerry Nadler will preside over the
hearing he says he will not grant a new
Republican request to hear from Hunter
Biden and the anonymous whistleblower or
anyone the whistleblower relied upon to
warn that mr. Trump was pressuring
Ukraine to investigate former Vice
President Joe Biden they can appeal to
the full committee if they wish and will
have a vote on that the White House has
chosen to stay out of the process we're
not gonna participate in a hearing where
the guilt is predetermined that just
makes no sense
over the weekend Democrats released a
new report that aimed to rebut some of
the most common Republican talking
points including the claim that there
was no quid pro quo they wrote the
evidence proves otherwise
meanwhile President Trump said his
personal attorney Rudy Giuliani wants to
give information to Congress that he
gathered on a recent trip to Ukraine
apparently it's aimed at discrediting
the impeachment inquiry some Republicans
said they welcomed Giuliani's findings
if he's getting relevant information
that comes comes forth from Ukraine I
think it's important for us to look at
CBS News has learned that drafts of the
articles of impeachment do already exist
but chairman Nadler says a final
decision on the charges like obstruction
of justice
an abuse of power will be made after all
the evidence is presented today gale boy
Nancy that's interested in here the
drafts already exist thank you very much